and I'm delighted to have her with us I
met
when she invited me to come to a
conference and speak with
together at an a me conference a few
months back and each each shared from
our from our perspectives and I was
incredibly impressed with Chelsea's
energy and enthusiasm about her
experience specifically about DBT in
that in that talk so I want to mention
that she's really been devoting herself
to these causes and just to give you an
example of how busy she is she is a
she's on the board of directors for Nami
Manchester Manchester Connecticut
she's a peer recovery group support
facilitator for Nami she is an our own
voice presenter and an end in ending the
silence presenter for middle school and
high school students just spoke to an
audience of 300 students yesterday she
is a parents and teachers as allies
presenter and she's also currently
attending Manchester Community College
to become a drug and alcohol recovery
counselor so thank you for joining us
please welcome Chelsea Chelsea come on
up
[Applause]
can you guys hear me okay all right cool
thanks for having me and as Seth
mentioned I do a lot of presentations
and I'm used to doing them with a
co-presenter so I get a little anxious
when I do it by myself so yeah again
yesterday I spoke to a class of 300 they
recently had two suicides at their house
or at their school so I came in and
talked to them my symptoms of borderline
personality disorder started around age
12 as a child I always had a fear of
abandonment which was rooted from the
neglect of my parents their busy
schedule caused them to not be available
as much as I wish they were it was an
unstable environment growing up my
parents when I attend school and
sporting events but they weren't there
emotionally specifically my dad who
traveled often there's a Salesman my mom
struggled with mental illness as well
and was able to show love and supported
the best she could but that didn't quite
make up for her not being there
physically present she worked two jobs
and what for one she worked second shift
and we leave for work as I was getting
off the school bus I wouldn't come home
around 11:00 p.m. I can strongly
remember hearing her come home and I
would climb into bed just to be near
here its death over there I was just
wondering if I can shut this laptop down
so that way I don't press any buttons
all right sweet thank you um so yeah in
my childhood throughout a lessons and
even now I suffered with attentions ayat
II and had quick mood chips I would go
from feeling happy to sad within a
couple of hours I had a deep feeling of
emptiness feeling like I was Hollow and
unable to ever get out of my own head I
also had a lack of sense of self and had
impulsive behaviors I first went to
therapy at age 16 after being
hospitalized for the first time due to
chronic cutting cutting was my first
real addiction an unhealthy coping
mechanism I don't recall how I turned to
it but it helped me with intense
emotions and made me feel better
around this time I started to cling
people then I would push them away I
remember
all too well of having my first
out-of-body experience I almost felt
like I was watching myself in a movie
that's a lot of what disassociate is
this association is about I was in the
car with my family on Long Island and
like I said I felt like I was watching
myself in a movie and that led to my
first panic attack and one of my family
members said it's just growing up you're
part of it's just part of growing up
you're at that age
and then there was around this time when
I also started becoming suicidal
I had this unexplainable feeling that
this was not just part of growing up but
that there was something really wrong
with me I had my first suicide attempt
at age 16 and when I was released from
the hospital
I remember how heart broke and my mom
was she cried and hugged me and said
Chelsea you were born prematurely with a
5% chance of living you were meant to be
alive I don't understand why you're
doing this to yourself I then started to
use drugs and alcohol on a regular basis
to cope with the unexpected death of my
mom age at age 18 she died of an
accidental drug overdose my use of
cocaine went from experimental to
addiction within a couple of months
cocaine quickly went from a way to deal
with a depression of my mom's death to
absolute chaos I was using daily for
about eight months and could not stop
cocaine quickly turned on me I began to
become paranoid while using when even
drive to New York and back just to come
down from the drug it's a time that I
never want to go back to again my use of
drugs particularly the use between 18
and 23 was more than just a bad coping
mechanism I used deadly combinations of
drugs and alcohol with the hope and
intent no overdosing so I am also
getting over a cold at the time I
thought it would have had sounded better
to my family if they knew that I had
died by a so-called accidental overdose
rather than my suicide thanks my friends
feared for my life during high school my
high school years throughout my early
20s mainly under the influence
particularly of cocaine and alcohol I
would make suicide gestures by asking
them things such as would you miss me if
I was
if I were going for a walk and we were
crossing a bridge
I would sarcastically ask if I jumped if
it would do the job while coming down
from cocaine I would leave sticky notes
on my forehead that would read if you
find me dead I'm sorry I really think I
was on a mission to die accidentally by
suicide overdosing my friends called
9-1-1 numerous times out of fear for not
only myself but for the people around me
i can't count the number of times i've
been admitted to the ER against my will
and between the age of 16 and 23 i
started to go through what I used to
call phases you know in high school you
go through a certain phase and I thought
I was just a normal teenager but I
didn't have a sense of self I first
identified as a tomboy I then idolized
my sister and very feminine then I
switched to what they would call the emo
face I don't know if anyone knows what
emo is you do okay because usually when
I say that everyone just gives me a
blank stare but yeah so I had like jet
black hair piercings the whole nine
yards I then went for the artist look
then a hippie phase
I even had a bumper sticker that read
reduce reuse recycle meanwhile I was
eating McDonald's and throwing like my
trash bags out of the car I was driving
it's like I care about the earth but
I've literally gone I'm so I desperately
wanted to discover myself and went to
great extremes to become all these
different characters that I created one
question that I get when I speak to is
uh how many personalities do I have so I
try to explain to them them I've always
been Chelsea I just didn't really know
who I was I returned to therapy at 23
under the suggestion and concerned from
a friend that it may be beneficial to
give another chance shortly after
returning to therapy I began cutting
again and after being sober for an
extended period of time
I relapsed and started using alcohol and
drugs daily after learning my dad was
ill with cancer after jumping back and
forth from an IOP and individual therapy
my therapist at that time referred me to
a DBT group at her agency when I first
attended
the group I was overwhelmed with fear
the source of my fear was joining a new
group and not knowing what I was getting
myself into I didn't understand anything
in the clinician was talking about but I
felt calm about this new form of therapy
my therapist now nearly four years was
the clinician Irina DBT group after a
few months I was sent back to the IOP
due to repeated suicide ideations
self-harm and substance abuse after
leaving the IOP I continued to attend
the weekly skills group and started to
understand the skills and modules a
little bit better it was around this
time that I was diagnosed with
borderline personality disorder I had
been previously misdiagnosed with
bipolar I sat down with my therapist who
I worked with off and on since I was 19
and we read through the nine symptoms
and I nodded my head and said yes I've
experienced all those difficulties I was
relieved at the diagnosis and felt that
the way I had been behaving and thinking
finally made sense despite still not
having a sense of self I felt hopeful
finally understanding that there was a
medical reason as to why I felt the way
I had been feeling my entire life there
was some shame that followed but after
practicing DBT I've been able to
radically accept it during one of my
last times attending the IOP the
clinician I was working with at the time
suggested I try going to the DBT program
at the IOL there was just the Institute
of living in Hertford she said the
repetition of the same program clearly
wasn't working and that DBT gets down to
the nuts and bolts and then I will find
a way to stall a way to self stop self
harming using and the risk of suicide
will be alleviated if I take advantage
of the program instantly the fear of
abandonment came up as I was in that
program and surrounded by the same
clinicians for such an extended period
of time
shortly after my intake for the DBT
program at the IOL I was able to
recognize that my father's health was
getting progressively worse
he went into home hospice care and
passed away peacefully peacefully with
family surrounding him I still regret
not being present during this time and
still tend to ruminate about the way I
treated him during the his ten month
battle
I often drove him to appointments under
the influence of substances I am very
grateful for the clinician who forced me
basically to tell my dad I loved him
before he passed and passed away and he
set it back that was the first time we
ever told each other we loved each other
I consider this true start of my
recovery taking place at the DBT program
at the IOL it was different than any
other outpatient program I had attended
as I've already shared I had a lot of
experience in outpatient programs I know
what gave me hope is the clinicians
practice DBT themselves it wasn't the
type of atmosphere where you felt like a
patient the clinicians talked about what
skills they used in their daily lives
for example one of the clinicians shared
how she's going to be skillful by
practicing mindfulness while bringing a
family member to a doctor's appointment
the clinician who I work with when I go
back to the program before what I like
to call a tuneup shares that shares
about how the fellow clinicians asked
her what skill she's using if she seems
to be struggling she shared with me once
that when she's feeling anxious at work
she goes outside and walks around the
campus of IOL to lower anxiety I could
use the entire 15 minutes I have and
share examples about how great it was to
be in a program where the clinicians
used the same skills they teach I can
honestly slight say that if I didn't go
I would not be standing here sharing my
story today there is no doubt in my mind
that I would be dead
I truly owe my life to the clinicians at
the DBT program at the Iowa and to the
clinicians at the IOP at NASA who
referred me to DBT they have saved my
life and two of them are actually in the
audience so try not to get all emotional
they're awesome I didn't even know they
were gonna be here to so today I'm no
longer ashamed of having borderline
personality disorder I try to call it
emotional dysregulation disorder because
I think that's what it should be called
I got stole that from Marsha Linehan I'm
yeah I'm Marshall Anakin's biggest fan
by the way too so it's still a challenge
to cope with symptoms I experienced but
I now have skills that I use to help
manage them
I'm now able to accept my emotions and
even love them which is something I
would never like think I would have ever
said before ever I don't try to push
them away because I've learned that they
come back even stronger when you push
them away I can still be hard on myself
at times but I remind myself that this
is a process instead of self harming I'm
able to self-soothe when I have an urge
to act on a certain behavior I urge surf
which is riding the urge like you would
surf a wave you watch the wait you watch
the urge come and go and eventually urge
passes
DBT skills truly work if you practice
them I no longer feel ashamed to ask for
help if I need it since its 2016 I have
an app called DBT 9-1-1 that I turned to
you basically every day I do my best to
make DBT a way of life just like the DBT
clinicians that I admire so greatly the
one thing I still struggle with is
radical acceptance which is letting go
of fighting reality acceptance is the
way out of pain I can radically accept
the little things
traffic burning my dinner etc but I
still struggle with radically accepting
the death of my parents with continued
practice and willingness to accept with
my heart that they're gone I've been
told by a former skills trainer at AOL
who lost her parents at a young age as
well that it will get easier with time
and it does take practice and I truly
believe that since the topic of suicide
I have lost a few friends to suicide I
have a few friends who are survivors of
suicide as well and I'm not gonna
sugarcoat it
I still get suicide ideations I don't
think they will ever go away completely
when their moderate I'm able to use DBT
skills and turn my mind by calling
someone or reaching out for help in any
way possible if the ideations do you
become severe I check myself into the ER
willingly sometimes I just stay there
for about 24 hours
my therapist works at CHR and they have
a mobile crisis team so if I call the
Assessment Center and and they become
concerned they actually come to my house
which is really comforting instead of
just talking with someone over the phone
[Music]
though I've had two of them come to my
house and I made them coffee and we've
sat down and talked it out until the
ideations passed I've I just grateful
exists so I'm not only grateful for the
clinicians at the DBT program IOL but
for my therapists that I've been working
with for nearly four years she disclosed
to me I mean this might be kind of
controversial but she disclosed to me
that in her experience there's a few
clinicians out there that fear with
working with people living with BPD due
to the high risk of suicide I feel like
that sounds like a judgement but I do
agree with her and it saddens me but I
am grateful that my therapist
understands me on the deepest level
possible I think she understands me more
than I understand myself
she's a DBT therapist and it's helped me
build a life worth living
she's likely had the biggest role in my
recovery and I feel lucky and honored to
be able to work with her Marshall
Lonnegan often talks about her goal for
people who come into treatment is to
build a life worth living to quote her
my main goal for people who come into
DBT treatment is that they get out of
hell and my second goal is that they
stay out of hell this is one of the main
reasons we teach skills because skills
are aimed at helping individuals build
lives that they themselves will
experiences worth living the idea is
that if you can build a life that you
experience is worth living you'll keep
living and you'll stay out of hell I can
now finally say that I am out of my own
hell and intend to stay out of hell
thanks to DBT my therapist and the
clinicians that I've worked with over
the past two and a half maybe three
years specifically the ones from the DBT
program at AOL building a life worth
living is something that I practice
every day I may start calling it
building a day worth living
[Applause]
[Music]